the German authorities want to retest a
saliva sample retrieved from the McCanns
holiday apartment the sample has already
tested negative for the suspect
Christian B's DNA and the Portuguese
police are resisting the German request
they don't see what more German
scientists can do with the sample if all
European countries use the same
techniques and the latest techniques
what could the Germans do differently I
don't know what the Germans are
anticipating that they might do there
are some newer techniques that people
are not generally using for routine
tests that they may want to do but I
don't see why the Portuguese also if
they had wanted to couldn't have
utilized those same specialists s the
German prosecutor hands Christiane
voltar's wouldn't discuss the request
when Sky News asked him he's admitted
he's struggling to find the forensic
evidence he needs to charge his suspect
he insists he has evidence Madeleine is
dead but he hasn't found her body tests
on the suspects campervan have yielded
no evidence of madeleine neither has his
Jaguar car Madeleine was nearly four
when she vanished in 2007 many forensic
samples from inside the apartment were
recovered and tested one unexplained
saliva sample from a bedspread
eventually showed the DNA of a boy whose
family had stayed there the week before
two weeks after their first Appeals for
the public's help it seems the German
and the British police and the
authorities here still haven't got the
key evidence they're desperate for the
local mayor has appealed to the suspects
criminal friends people with a criminal
background don't deal readily with the
authorities I appeal to such friends of
the suspect to tell us anything they
know if they don't want to speak
directly to the police then they can
email the information in jail in Germany
the suspect Christian B has reportedly
told his lawyer he had nothing to do
with Madeline's disappearance Martyn
Brandt Sky News Portugal